you know what i watched lex friedman's
podcast with mark zuckerberg actually
really really interesting
i i still think mark zuckerberg is a
villain but a podcast definitely
humanizes someone even if they're if
their answers are all you know yeah
[ __ ] tailored by their pr team or
whatever i don't know you do you do get
to know somebody a lot more when you
listen to them for two and a half hours
or whatever i think it was like almost
three hours but it's really interesting
you should watch it all about like how
he thinks about the metaverse and i'll
watch it and then uh probably just buy
like 10 more oculus headsets excuse me
metaverse excuse me facebook vr headset
yeah not a brand deal though i just like
the product it's a great product yeah
and cheap too yeah sorry it's not cheap
it's a bargain for what you get oh is
that his messaging no no
well he just said some some interesting
things like for example like how
important eye contact is
yeah you know how important it is in
real world conversation and how on zoom
you literally never do it ever yeah
because one person is constantly looking
at the screen the other person is like
also looking at the screen i'm pretty
sure he he said he makes he makes the
company do like 40 of their meetings in
vr oh that's weird could you imagine
that how sick you'd feel just a whole
day of being just a floating body a
roblox server basically that would
immediately i feel reduced the
importance of the meeting you're all
just like these goofy avatars yeah like
oh look at me cool i'll have that look
at them t-rex anyways i'll have that
presentation to you by uh end of week
thanks so much and you take off the
goggles
i mean the good part is you're always
going to look awake you could just
straight up be asleep during a meeting
but your [ __ ] avatar is like
zach are you good back there's like
motion detection on the helmet isn't
there on the goggles yeah but if you're
like how funny if your avatar just yeah
no but your eyes are opening in space
like
your eyes are open
because your avatar's like expressions
yeah
yeah
no even when you're asleep you'd be like
yeah
yo man are you good back there
it's like no one wants this war and it
seems like everyone's kind of against
putin right now so no honestly um hope
you're staying safe over there if you've
gone through some [ __ ] over there is
there somewhere like people can like
donate yeah i donated uh [ __ ] riot they
started to oh so dao on party bid yeah
which is just so happens to me marcus's
company that's how i found out about it
yeah but um they they're basically like
a crowdsourcing resource for
funds and for it's for like pooling
money to buy nfts but you can do it you
can collect funds for anything so and i
would say riot started a fund and i
donated in ethereum
you can do two i would just go to
party.bid i think or just search party
bid on google and then it'll like it's
advertised on their site i would
actually trust [ __ ] riot as well
because they've they've gone to russian
prison yeah they've been like [ __ ] you
they've actually gone at the system so
yeah shout out to that if you have any
resources man drop that [ __ ] in the
comments yeah um and we'll try to signal
boost that ukraine down ukraine though
hell yeah so far they're at
50 over 1500 eats which is how much is
the total i can't see 4.6 million 4.6
million bucks they've raised yeah i read
somewhere i don't know if this is true
or not you another thing is that you can
never trust anything you read yeah when
war is happening so much of it is
propaganda yeah i have no idea what to
believe what not to believe but i read
that the ukraine government is offering
forty thousand dollars in crypto to any
russian soldiers who defect i guess like
the average salary for them is like
eight thousand bucks american a year so
that's like years of salary yeah rough
for them to defect it's just like a
pretty big brain move yeah if yeah here
it is ukraine offers russian soldiers
compensation if they surrender like you
think about these 18 to 20 year old guys
yeah who don't know why they're fighting
who are probably [ __ ] scared shitless
who are seeing their tanks get taken by
ukraine the amount of like sheer
supplies that russia has lost yeah in
this war is like so much larger than
anything else supposedly they're also
rolling around with like a mobile
crematorium so they can hide the losses
yeah we're production assistant's
ukrainian and he has like family over
there they're like you know and
unnaturally i mean you know he was like
pretty shaken up because he's just
describing to me the things that they're
going through and
that [ __ ] made me feel so helpless i'm
like i feel for him because like he's
sitting there and his family's texting
him all this brutal stuff and it's like
he's sitting there like what can i do i
mean what can you do it's yeah that's i
think that's the worst part of war is
like the people who are going through it
it's like
there's almost nothing like it feels so
hopeless yeah like you picture yourself
as a 20 year old dude that's like yeah
all of a sudden you're faced with or
you're you're offered four years of
salary yeah to bail to bail and you
don't know you don't want to fight in
the first place yeah mobile crematorium
is like the wildest [ __ ] i've ever heard
even though russia's losing more
soldiers than ukraine no russia is oh
they they have them they can hide the
damage yeah so they can hide the losses
wow yeah i mean death is not sick but i
mean it's just sick that ukraine is oh
yeah not backing down oh no working but
it's not sick that now the entire fate
of the world is in the hands of a psycho
this [ __ ] psychopath yes ego problems
yeah total [ __ ] yeah well i do have to
you know i feel like it's it's worth
mentioning like big rest in peace to the
to the people on snake island oh yeah
how hard was that yeah you got it you
gotta [ __ ] honor that yeah they're
all alive yeah oh no they're not yeah
they're alive yeah all 12 of them how
it came out that they're all
still alive
let me see if i can find it whoa holy
[ __ ] that's badass
damn they're the ones by the way if you
don't know they're the ones that told
the russian
combat ship to go [ __ ] themselves yeah
basically this russian warship pulled up
and was like surrender now they opened
fire on them i think yeah they didn't
doesn't that tape end with like
explosions or something yeah something
kind of like [ __ ] ukrainian uh
these these ukrainian soldiers that were
on snake island were like you know the
russians call out to them to say
surrender or you know we will attack and
then they're like or you hear a guy say
should i tell them to go [ __ ] themselves
yeah and then the woman says yeah just
in case and he goes copy that go [ __ ]
yourself
damn dude hard as hell damn you gotta
imagine too if you just signed up
to go to like the russian navy because
you need a job and you're on that ship
and now you're told like all right we're
gonna go fight now and then you're
standing around in the room and the guy
like leading you is like yo we're gonna
attack you and the people you're
attacking are like cool [ __ ] bring it
suck my dick you're like
yeah dude i don't know we don't really
want to anymore that's a good idea
i don't know dude did you see the kid
that's that made the twitter account
following the russian oligarchs jets no
he's the same kid that made a twitter
account that follows where elon's jet
goes and i think elon elon has expressed
like you know he didn't doesn't like
that at all because it compromises his
safety or something like that but now
this same kid has done the same thing
using some like open api with flight
data where you can track where the
russian oligarchs are going and i'm sure
none of them are there
not not in russia yeah that's what i
know they're still flying around the
world but it's like that seems like a
pretty risky thing to do oh deaf like
this kid's like putting his life on the
line yeah
well
maybe where is he from
does anyone know
anything about him jack sweeney the
college student college student wow
click on the twitter that's a good way
to just
[Laughter]
get assassinated yeah or just even like
you know
hey by the way if you're fighting for
russia these people don't care about you
yeah they're nowhere near that [ __ ]
so what does that tell you well they're
probably trying to go like protect their
assets in los angeles oh i mean
nothing
yeah let's just read these out
yeah that's a good idea that's kind of
interesting though you get to see where
these boys like you know
were they where they hang out yeah
you